so as we continue our discussion on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four we
actually wrap up this story with its
conclusion and so what I wanted to do is
actually backtrack for a second with the
return of Galactus and the reason why is
because in the last video I actually got
carried away he admittedly I was I was
so just taken away by the events that
were unfolding that I didn't quite
include some of the information that
needed to be discussed and what I mean
here is that if you guys recall we had
talked about how Johnny Storm had been
killed facing off against the Horde of
Annihilus in the negative zone and again
the reason why this was done is because
Jonathan Hickman was basically building
up to this idea of earth being this
giant battleground that the forces of a
nihilist wanted to invade the earth that
the Kree Armada wanted to invade the
earth to destroy the Inhumans that the
that these forces of the audit lanterns
wanted to take back the surface world
that the people within the forever city
who had their evolution sped up by the
ascension engine wanted to take back the
surface and so it was basically
everybody descending onto the surface of
the earth or coming to earth in some
form or fashion well with Johnny Storm
what we learned here is that while he
did die per se during the forces of
Annihilus and he was actually
resurrected using the worms of Annihilus
and the words of a nihilists are
basically one aspect of the forces of
the negative zone but had the ability to
basically heal the body of mortal people
and bring them back to life now this is
this really I guess requires us where
Hitler requires us to does kind of
suspend disbelief here to basically say
that yes Johnny Storm was dead his soul
never left his body was just kind of
hanging there and he kept coming back
but the goal of Annihilus and bringing
Johnny Storm back to life was to
effectively torture him and he did this
in a couple ways the first way was to
show Johnny storm pictures of the earth
his intention to invade it to destroy
all life on planet but the other half
was to acquire the access codes to
access the gate that would let him
invade the the universe invade Earth but
Johnny Storm wouldn't give him this
information and so the result was at a
nihilist kept killing and resurrecting
Johnny Storm
now while Johnny Storm was being killed
and resurrected once the time came when
Annihilus was approached by the
alternate version of Reed Richards from
a different universe who offered a
nihilist the
to access earth if Annihilus was willing
to help him in turn then there was no
need for Johnny Storm and so johnny was
basically put in a prison and so because
of this johnny began talking to other
prisoners around there and it began
taking some coaxing it took a little bit
of work on his behalf but the idea here
is that in the eyes of Johnny's store
because he's fought against a nihilist
so often because he's met Annihilus on a
multitude of occasions being that the
villain Annihilus first appeared as one
of the earliest enemies of the Fantastic
Four that Johnny knows how to defeat him
and the way to defeat Annihilus is to
capture his cosmic control rod now if
those of you guys who have seen my video
on Franklin Richards explained we had
talked about the cosmic control rod and
then this is actually the source of
Franklin's powers the Franklin is a
mutant per se but Marvel never really
gives us an actual explanation they
never really Square this circle in terms
of Franklin's mutant powers and the fact
that he can warp reality but the fact
remains that because of his abilities
because of what he's capable of this is
all a byproduct to the fact that when he
was being born because of the fact that
Susan storms life was being threatened
because it was possible that she would
die in the birthing process because of
the complications that Franklin was
presenting that that Reed Richards and
Ben Grimm and Johnny Storm traveled to
the negative zone they met Annihilus for
the first time they captured his cosmic
control rod which allows annihilist who
harnessed cosmic energies and then
brought that back to earth and used that
in order for Susan storm to give birth
to Franklin so Franklin and the cosmic
control rod are really part and parcel
to one another with the factory names
that Annihilus is able to control the
forces of the annihilation wave using
the cosmic control rod so for those of
you guys who are always curious as to
how it is a nihilist maintains complete
control over these virtually endless
amounts of forces and so on he does it
by virtue of the cosmic control rod
because it basically allows him to
control the negative zones equivalent of
the power cosmic and so what happens is
that once Johnny and these various I
guess prisoners begin to band together
when the event is taking place whereby
the portal is supposed to be open and
Annihilus is supposed to send his forces
in Johnny Storm in his group make their
presence known and they basically
initiate their attack and what they do
is they start assaulting as many forces
as they can but the goal is to both
distract Annihilus as well as take as
cosmic control rod
well the problem is that because
Annihilus is relatively intelligent in
terms of battle tactics in terms of
warfare he immediately knows what it is
that they're trying to do and so as they
descend on a nihilist he basically
starts killing off every single one of
them and it also really boils down to
Annihilus and Johnny Storm fighting one
another and so initially Hickman doesn't
tell us exactly how things turn out all
we know is that the cosmic control rod
when flying out of the hand of Annihilus
and both he and Johnny Storm were
reaching for it but what happens is that
things begin to pan out that we begin to
get a bigger picture of what's going on
and we see that Johnny Storm harnessed
the cosmic control rod and this is
really interesting because for those of
you guys who are familiar with Johnathan
Hickman's run on Avengers and New
Avengers during time runs out that led
up to Secret Wars and even during Secret
Wars itself a constant theme was
everything dies and this again is
basically hickman harkening back to his
own story to the Fantastic Four there's
a lot of crossover between the stories
at hickman rights during his time in
Marvel Comics that's why I say you can
basically read Hickman's Fantastic Four
you can read his secret warriors you can
read his his short-term run on shield
and you can read time runs out in secret
Wars all in chronological order and it
tells a self-contained story outside of
the rest of Marvel's cosmology but the
fact remains here that with Johnny Storm
having the power of the of the cosmic
control rod he's almost on the same
level as God now one of the big things
to differentiate here is that the cosmic
control rod is used in relation to the
person who's wielding it and so while it
does have incredible power it doesn't
mean you'll have the power of God it
certainly just means that you're going
to be able to use it for whatever
purpose you best know how in the case of
Johnny Storm he's basically able to
amplify his own powers to manipulate
plasma and fire based energies now from
here we actually jump and again this is
all before the arrival of Galactus on
earth at the end of our last video we
jump to the Fantastic Four meeting
Galactus on the moon and the reason why
this matters is because those of you
guys who were curious at the end of our
last video how it was that Reed had
summoned Galactus this is how what
happens is Reed is provided with an
artifact called the Ark and what
Galactus says is that on earth there's
what's called a Galactus seed now some
of you guys may have heard of this some
of you guys during your travels across
the Marvel Wikipedia or something like
that or on reddit or in your forums or
something on those lines may have heard
of a phrase
called the galactic seed or that I guess
the Galactus seed and what this is is
when Galactus was originally birthed so
to speak into the universe when he came
into existence the cosmic entity
eternity which represents the entire I
guess encompasses the entirety of the
universe had basically created a means
for the universe to be reborn once it's
destroyed and this is what the Galactus
seed is the Galactus seed is basically
this reality's version of Galactus who
will be born anew in the new universe
the problem with this is that there are
individuals who seek to harness that
Galactus seed and we'll find out who
those people are but with the Galactus
seed here on earth the issue is that if
somebody were to get a hold of it and if
somebody were to use it
it's an immature Galactus it's not a
fully fleshed out Galactus and the
result is that it would replace Galactus
himself and bring something much much
worse now hickman doesn't exactly tell
us what that is
and we don't really need to know per se
because we never really find out but
what happened was after eternity had
created the Galactus seed and put it on
earth it was eventually discovered by
the Asgardians and the Asgardians had
taken the Galactus seed and put it in
Asgard which is where the world tree
comes from and so that's why if you guys
hear people say things like Galactus is
searching for the Glatt to seed and it's
on Asgard this is what they're talking
about this is what they're referring to
now Kaitlynn does a little bit of
retconning here what he says is that
because the Galactus II was discovered
by by Bohr who was the man who
originally created as guard that Bohr
had used the khalaqtu seed to create the
universe but again we're not really
going with that we're kind of relying on
my interpretation with regards to a
history of the Marvel Universe and so
this is just a bit of information if you
choose to pursue it you're more than
welcome to but I wouldn't really take it
as gospel truth just because of the fact
that Jonathan Heyman doesn't really
provide a full scale explanation on this
but what happens here is Galactus says
that a time is coming an event is going
to be taking place relatively soon
whereby his presence will be needed
people have to be summoned by Reed
Richards and when that time comes Reed
will know when that moment arrives he'll
know what time or I guess when to summon
Galactus at which point he will do that
and so what happens here is we basically
we transition a bit and we actually pick
up with this really interesting
childlike story of Franklin Richards now
this is very very very important this is
wildly important and the reason why is
because this is going to help connect
the dots this is gonna go from point A
to point B especially when we get to the
adult version of Franklin Richards
what happened here is it actually jumps
back to to the point at which the adult
Franklin Richards had woken up the power
of a younger self and initially Franklin
had experimented of course he had
created a pocket universe and then just
kind of give us a run over of the things
that we've seen so far that Franklin
made this pocket universe but didn't
know what to do with it so he put it in
a closet and then Johnny Storm died and
everybody mourned for Johnny storm and
that kind of thing but then what happens
is Franklin and Leach actually go into
the closet to see what happened to that
universe that Franklin had made and what
happens is once they tumble in they end
up on a fully formed earth this earth
has inhabitants and has people has cars
it has all kinds of stuff what we
actually learned is there's villains
there's good guys there's bad guys it's
it really is just a completely formed
reality in and of itself and so what
happens is Franklin and leach of course
go on their own little escapades and
they fight their own adventures and what
we would expect for kids to do of course
they make their little jokes and things
like that but when does it up happening
is a person a man that we can't see
visits the two of them and he says you
guys can do a whole lot better than this
you know Franklin you can do much much
better than what you've done here and so
he basically takes them on a tour of
this universe and what we learn is that
of course in addition to this this earth
being fully formed that Franklin has
basically created everything he's
created a whole functioning fully
working universe in and of itself he's
created life he's created gods he's done
all that kind of stuff and so what this
unknown man does is he asked leach he
says if you can create everything if
Franklin made everything in this
universe then what does that make
Franklin and leaf says it makes him God
and so this is a very important thing to
remember because what we'll find out is
that in a lot of ways Franklin is a god
it's crazy the kind of things that he
can do again especially when we get to
his older self and so what we do here is
we pick back up again with the Cree
our mana which is invading the planet
Earth again this is prior to the arrival
of Galactus as he was summoned by read
at the end of our last video but we pick
up with a Kree armada who is who are
attacking the planet Earth and of course
we have the Avengers and we have you
know what's what's remained or I guess
what remains of the Fantastic Four we
have a multitude of forces who are all
doing their best but because of the fact
that Annihilus forces had already begun
the process of opening the portal prior
to his defeat by Johnny Storm
once the portals open johnny emerges
with Annihilus as his prisoner and meets
Peter Parker and this is a big deal
because they all thought Johnny Storm is
dead everyone believed that he had long
since been gone and so what happens as
Peter tells Johnny says hey look man yes
it's cool that you took out an AI
Alissa's forces but we have a lot of
other stuff going on too Earth is
effectively being invaded by everybody
and so what happens is that as they're
fighting their way through as they're
attempting to to battle I guess the the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four are
tending to battle these various Kree
forces Johnny Storm makes his signature
for in the sky and this is basically him
telling everybody that he's back and
this is a really cool moment this is a
really great aspect of Hickman's run
because he could have just appeared as
Susan storm and Reed Richards and Ben
Grimm and could have said hey guys I'm
back but for him to basically create his
his little insignia the Fantastic Four
insignia in the sky this is a hallmark
of Johnny storms character and so what
better way to bring him back to the land
of the living than to have him do the
one thing that he's best known for which
is to create his signature and so of
course it takes pin Grimm and it takes
us Reed Richards and Susan storm by
surprise but it also empowers them
because they're like Johnny storms back
we can do anything now and the reason
why this is important is because after
the death of Johnny Storm none of them
felt whole they felt like a portion of
them was gone like it was missing but
now that they know Johnny Storm is back
the Fantastic Four is complete again
they all have that part of themselves
that was missing and it reflects itself
in the fact that Ben Grimm musters from
near sheer defeat and rallies himself
along with all the other Avengers and
the other I guess the remainder of the
Fantastic Four and continue their attack
against the Kree Armada and so once a
Johnny Storm is officially welcomed to
back of course again the Avengers and
and all these various forces begin to
rally themselves and at the same time
that
mata continues its onslaught of attacks
against everybody and so what we do here
is we basically pick up with the end of
the last video and the return of
Galactus as he was summoned by Reed
Richards
now again what's funny here is that when
Galactus arrives he says why am I here
why have you summoned me to this place
and Reed says well you told us when we
knew it was time and it's time like it's
time of you that you are here because we
assume this is what you meant and
Galactus says no this is not why you
were supposed to call me you were
supposed to call me because there's
something much worse coming than this
and again Hickman doesn't really tell us
what it is that Galactus is referring to
but Galactus says of course he'll take
care of the Kree Armada and he
immediately just wipes out virtually
everybody and so of course you have
again the leader of the Kree the supreme
intelligence he's on his on his head
ship and his forces are asking him what
do we do how are we supposed to deal
with this and once ago like us
obliterates these forces the the supreme
intelligence says let's just go in
addition to this Galactus says after
destroying these forces that the reason
why he was supposed to be here has
finally made itself present and the fact
that the mad Celestials have now
appeared at the planet Earth now again
for those of you guys who have not seen
my series so far the mad Celestials were
Celestials from an alternate reality
whereby they had gone insane and they
had forced the denizens of that reality
to worship them but when Reed Richards
went in to visit the Council of reeds
the the mad Celestials were awakened if
they were made aware of the council by
the actions of another version of Reed
Richards and so the the mad Celestials
had found their way into the council
they had begun killing off all the reeds
and the last we knew was that they had
basically taken over the council chamber
itself but we didn't know where it was
that they were going to we didn't know
what direction they were heading in and
really Hickman had never really given us
anything with regards to these
individuals up until this point and so
what happens is initially everybody is
just kind of flabbergasted they're
they're totally stunned here and
Galactus says you
I need to leave you guys do not need to
be here and so when they initially say
no Galactus you need to go away we're
going to consume this plan we're going
to destroy this world we're gonna take
this universe as our own Galactus tells
them to read his mind so that he they
can understand word as it he's coming
from and when this happens the mad
Celestials realized that Galactus knows
where they come from
he knows what their will is and so the
mad Celestials then turn and begin
fighting Galactus and so as effectively
Galactus against four Celestials now
with Reed Richards he's watching these
events unfold and he initially doesn't
want to leave and admittedly I probably
wouldn't want to either I'd want to see
how this event unfolds fortunately we
are the reader which means we get to see
what happens and so as Galactus is
facing off against these against these
Celestials of course again the Kree
Armada bails out they all take off the
Inhumans go back to the planet earth
everybody's just kind of like this is
way too big for us we visit we got no
dog in this fight and they all start
bailing out and so all that's really
left here are the Fantastic Four and of
course Galactus fighting off these
Celestials so while he is able to kill
one of them the fact remains and the
Celestials are still wildly powerful in
and of themselves and what they do is
they merge and they combine into one
mega celestial and this mega celestial
Dwarfs Galactus and size as well as
overpowers Galactus with the greatest of
ease now when Galactus is overpowered
and he is effectively killed and sent
back to the planet Earth what this does
is this ties in to the old man Logan
story that we had talked about where in
that future reality of old man Logan
those individuals had found the body of
Galactus or had used the body of
Galactus and brought him back and so
this this is again another example of
how all of Hickman's stuffed highs in
about how all of hitman's stuff comes
together and it basically wraps up all
these different plot holes and things
like that and so what we do is we follow
the Fantastic Four as they head back to
Sol's anvil now again Sol's anvil was
created by the alternate reality
versions of read for the purpose of
basically destroying any sort of being
that could arrive on earth and try to
usurp their will but we actually also
learned that it was designed for the
purpose of destroying these these mad
Celestials and so what happens is that
while Galactus is presumably dead and
these mad Celestials are making their
way towards Earth or descending into
Earth that read begins to power up Sol's
anvil and what he does is he
shoots it at this mega celestial and it
completely disperses the Celestials
armor now reads initial response here is
to say that the the engine is charging
back up again and they'll be ready for
another shot but its father says no it
doesn't matter you never get any more
than one shot and that's exactly what
happens as soon as that shot goes off
and the Celestials physical bodies are
forced to to break apart back into their
three normal forms they basically attack
the entire facility and they destroy
Sol's anvil and so with Johnny stolen
empowered by the cosmic control rod he
uses his newfound powers to damage one
of the Celestials but again that's all
he does all he does is damage them and
so they immediately turn on Johnny storm
and they take him out now they don't
kill him they simply just incapacitate
him and so Susan storm uses her powers
to create force fields to basically
block off the block off Reed Richards
and spider-man valaria richards franklin
and herself to keep them safe from the
powers of the Celestials this is
actually really interesting here because
what Hickman is telling us is that the
force fields that Susan storm can make
are able to withstand the power of a
celestial and this is pretty big this is
pretty significant there are very very
very few people in fact you can really
count them on one hand that can create
force fields that can withstand a cosmic
level beings and so this is Hickman
basically telling us Susan storm yes
she's the one that kind of keeps the
family in check but she's not somebody
to walk over she's not someone to snuff
who knows that she's pretty damn
powerful and the kind of things that she
can do and so again while she does her
best to try to hold everybody off in the
end
the shield just doesn't quite hold and
so Reed Richards and Franklin Richards
spider-man Nathanael they all seem to be
completely taken out and what happens
here is Hickman harkens back to Valerius
conversation with her mother which she
had traveled into the past and she had
said that things are going to get very
bad things are going to get very very
dark they're gonna be dark and they're
gonna be full of loss and it's going to
feel like everything is going to shatter
that the world is going to break apart
that nothing's going to be able to hold
and when that time comes that Susan
needs to keep everything together she's
to keep herself together as best you can
and keep on fighting no matter what
happens and so again in this last little
bit of recollection valaria had told
Susan when the
comes when you feel like you can't fight
anymore and you want to give up look
into the sky and remember the price that
was paid and so what happens I love this
part of the story so much and so what
happens is a light opens up above Susan
storm and when she looks up it's the
adult Franklin Richards and valaria now
this is some because this is when
things get awesome
this is when things get so good it make
it's so amazing
so of course Susan's reaction to the the
future version of her son Franklin and
valaria is oh my god this is so awesome
this is so cool but Nathaniel says it
worked
and this is when Hickman starts wrapping
things up this is when he basically
begins to ramp up and answer all these
questions that we had about the story up
to this point so for those of you guys
who may have found yourselves a little
lost a little confused trying to
understand what direction this was all
going in this is this is going to take
care of that because this is Hickman
riding Hickman starts from the end and
works his way to the beginning whenever
he writes stories he actually said that
an interview it's really cool here but
what happens is Franklin appears before
one of the Celestials and when they
analyze him they immediately say that
he's beyond omega' classification that
he is a he's a galactic danger he's a
galactic constant he's a Universal
shaper now for those of you guys who
don't know what this means it means
Franklin Richards controls the Marvel
Universe that he controls everything
that he can make the universe what he
wants it to be then he is easily
equivalent to the Celestials in power
but the idea here is that he's actually
not and this is what's interesting a
hickman kind of blurs the line between
the adult Franklin Richards and what it
is that he's capable of and the reason
why I say that is because we don't know
how powerful these Celestials are in
comparison to a normal being for example
Galactus was able to destroy one of them
but the three of them were able to form
themselves into a singular entity and
take out Galactus and so the question is
if they did that again would they
destroy Franklin Richards
but before they're able to do that
Franklin Richards effectively whisks
them away he simply sends them to
another part of the universe now this
keeps them sort of confused and it keeps
them at bay and this is actually what
Franklin says he basically says it'll
confuse them for a little bit but we
also learned here that this was all part
of the bigger plan this was part of a
plan that was orchestrated by Nathanael
valaria and Franklin himself now this
plan will be explained here in a couple
minutes but something I want you to take
note of is that Franklin actually asked
for the powers of his younger self and
this is why this matters is because
referencing our discussion on the man
that visited Franklin while he and leach
were exploring the universe this was his
older self the older adult Franklin
Richards was basically training his
younger self and how to use his powers
and so that when the time came Franklin
would be able to store those energies
inside of himself and give them to his
older self and so basically the future
Franklin Richards has twice as much
power as he normally would which is
insane and so once the once the mad
Celestials make their return to Franklin
Richards descends and begins to engage
them in battle and this is where Hickman
begins to answer our questions reads
question is can Franklin win on his own
and Nathanael says no he cannot he
cannot win this battle by himself it's
just not possible now again this is
where I say that that Hickman sort of
blurs the line here because we've read
stories where Franklin has fought
multiversal entities and won but in this
particular situation he's not able to
face the Celestials on his own and
succeed but what in Fanueil says is that
Franklin will find a way but he always
has to find a way and again Nathanael
begins to give us some answers here
what if angle tells us is that this was
the day this moment right now this was
the day that all of Reed's actions had
caught up to him but Franklin Richards
was the one that figured it out
Franklin Richards was the one that
realized that if his father could be
saved
the future the universe could be spared
and so when Reid asks how it is that I
got to this point what it is that
resulted in this situation what
Nathaniel tells us is that there are
universal constants there are things
that will always happen and just cannot
be changed and one of the things was
that Reid always created the portal in
every reality he always created the
portal in every reality he always walked
into the portal and met those versions
of himself in every instance where
Nathaniel has travelled back into the
past and tried to change things they've
always happened the exact same way that
Reed Richards has been part of the
council that he built Agassiz fix sons
that he built universes that the mad
Celestials were always woken up and that
Reid always escaped but the mad
Celestials always came back and they
always kill read every single time they
always killed Reed Richards
but what Nathaniel says is that there
comes a time as a parent where you just
kinda have to step back you have to
realize that you've done everything you
can as a parent but you've taught your
children everything you can and that who
they are is who they're going to be for
the rest of their lives but Franklin was
not happy about that Franklin was not
willing to accept that Franklin wanted
his father to live and that is the basis
of this story the entire run of Jonathon
Hickman's Fantastic Four is Franklin
Richards trying to save his dad's life
and so what happens here is Franklin
basically uses the power of his younger
self and brings Galactus back to life
not only that he does it in the most
awesome way possible he throws the
energy into Galactus and summons
Galactus as his Herald now how awesome
is that it's one of the coolest things
in the entire run of Marvel Comics and
hickman gives us this this amazing you
know discussion here he gives us this
amazing monologue while everyone is
watching on while the Fantastic Four are
watching these events unfold they're
literally look
at Franklin as an adult who possesses
powers of a god he possesses powers
hitherto unrivaled by anybody in the
Marvel Universe saved maybe Matthew
Malloy and even then that's that's
that's a stretch and so while Galactus
and Franklin aren't able to successfully
take on all these things what happens is
that Nathaniel basically says the reason
why Franklin went back in the first
place the reason why Franklin chose to
save his father's life in the first
place is because Reed abandoned the
council and that is as one act that's
the one saving grace in all the other
members of the council they had all left
their families they had all abandoned
their children they had abandoned Susan
made a ban and Ben Grimm they had
abandoned all their own realities
versions of their their family and
friends but our sick earth-616 version
of Reed did not do that
and the result was that he had a son
that wanted to see him live Franklin
wanted him to come back to life and so
what happens is that as this battle is
beginning come to a close as it's
beginning to wrap up that the explosion
the death of these Celestials creates a
light in the sky that rivals that of the
Sun and everyone sees it every single
person sees a Captain America and the
Avengers the white Mane's who were
fighting alongside Reed Richards the
Future Foundation but at the same time
it also harkens to the fact that this
this light but sort of explodes into the
sky is representative of the fact that
everything's changing now that
everything's moving in a totally
different direction that Marvel now has
a player on the chessboard who could
effectively dominate everybody else but
more so than that then it harkens to the
idea of all these heroes on earth the
Avengers the Fantastic Four you know
whatever members from the x-men chose to
fight that they all single-handedly save
the universe or save their world in what
was probably one of the most extreme
battles in the universe and it all just
sort of harkens back to this idea
at Franklin Richards seems to have Paris
in the conflict but in fact that he
didn't that basically it gave the chance
for humanity to effectively start over
again to sort of rectify its ways in
light of the fact that a single man
saved them from complete and total
annihilation and so as this begins to
wrap up as this this story begins to
come to a close we transition to the
epilogue and what we do is we actually
pick back up it's kind of a I guess a
throwback to the beginning of the story
would read Richards father Nathaniel was
telling him to jump off a jungle gym and
Nathaniel would catch him and he was
designed to teach bravery he was
designed to teach read that is okay to
fail that is okay to to make mistakes
but it's not okay to quit before you
even start and so Franklin as a child is
terrified of this situation and so while
his of course adult self is watching on
alongside Susan and Ben Graham and
Johnny Storm and spider-man and so on
Reed tells his son the exact same thing
he tells them it's okay to fail it's
okay to make mistakes but to not even
try is completely unacceptable and so
Reid tells Franklin do it do his best do
the best that he absolutely can and so
Franklin for the first time in the
history of his life as a young child
begins to let his powers flourish in a
way that that simply hasn't been seen
before
by simply jumping into the sky and
flying with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end there is
some more stuff that happens after this
but if you want to know what it is you
got to buy the story and read it but I
really hope you guys enjoyed this
because Hickman's run of the Fantastic
Four is probably one of the best things
that you're ever going to read and
Marvel Comics it is incredible but I
hope you guys really enjoyed it if you
did make sure you drop a like throw some
comments down let me know what you guys
think and yeah I will catch you all
later peace